[Music]
unless you live in a cave and your only
source of news is visual politic in
which case thank you very much you
probably realize that Fidel Castro died
and with his death a communist icon
disappears Fidel Castro ruled over Cuba
with an iron fist for over 50 years now
many people wonder where the Fidel's
death will be the first step in a
transition for Cuba a transition from a
communist dictatorship to a liberal
democracy so the reality is is that
Fidel Castro retired from politics in
2008 handing over power to his little
brother Raul Castro keeping Cuba really
in the family business the truth is that
Raul found himself having to apply
several reforms in Cuba reforms that not
such a long time ago would have been
impossible to imagine in a regime that
touted itself as the perfect communist
system clearly Castro ISM is done at
least the way we know it no one really
knows what will become of Cuba but one
thing is for a salute certain it's
changing well you all asked for a video
about Cuba and you know that here a
visual politic we do like to think
outside of the box so in this video
we're answering a very important
question that we believe has been
answered yet is now a good time to
invest in Cuba is it possible to make
money out of these political changes
that are expected on the island today
we're going to answer that question
history shows us that when an economy
goes from a planned one to a free-market
one there is a window of time where it's
possible to make a fortune a good
example of this is the Czech Republic
particularly in the city of Prague where
I'm making this video I am British but I
live in Prague now at the beginning of
the 1990s the Czech Republic was opening
up its economy for the first time after
decades of communism this means that for
the first time in years you could buy
and sell houses
but not only that since the country was
relatively poor the price of property
was very low this attracted a lot of
foreign investors particularly from the
north of Italy they were buying property
for almost no money at all then years
later the Czech economy started growing
fast foreign company who came and
settled down here tourism grew and local
people started companies in a short time
the price of houses doubled and those
people who invested early became
millionaire a very similar thing might
just happen in Cuba but hold on just a
second because this isn't quite as
simple as it sounds other former
communist countries like the Ukraine
didn't have the same amount of luck and
more than one investor invested in
post-communist Ukraine has gone bankrupt
before considering investing in Cuba
it's important to understand what's
going on in the country what is the
nature of the reforms that are taking
place but before we get into all of that
let's take a look the situation Cuba
today
Cuba is a communist country this means
that their whole economy is directed by
the government for some clarity in the
good times the Cuban government employed
92 percent of the country's people this
means that almost everyone was working
in the public sector
those were the 1980s when Cuba exported
sugar tobacco and all sorts of fruit to
the Soviet Union but in 1989 the Berlin
Wall came down in Fidel Castro lost his
trading partner
[Music]
passivist the US embargo which forbids
American companies from doing any kind
of business with the island and Cuba was
practically isolated from the rest of
the world this resulted in a brutal
economic crisis that lasted until the
year 2000 fist-width when sugar Shaban
came to power in Venezuela as you could
see in another one of our videos
Venezuela used to be a very oily tree
and since Chavez and Castro with such
good buddies Chevelle's gave a lot of
money to cap this was the life raft that
was supporting Castro's revolution
nevertheless in 2013 oil prices
collapsed and so did Venezuela's economy
and of course with all that money drying
up in no longer went to Cuba and Cuba's
economy collapsed as well now at this
time Fidel was already retired and his
brother Raul had taken the reins of the
country Raul Castro realized that Cuba
was once again isolated and he needed to
change a lot of things or his country
was going to get a whole lot worse Raul
Castro Chinese reform by the way just I
should say now if you're enjoying the
music in today's video it's by a singer
and composer called
Rick belt Rik he's from Medellin
Colombia if you like it you will find
links to his music in the description
[Music]
beloved of Allah
alright ok back to 2013 and Raul Castro
announcing a series of reforms in Cuba
the first reform was the legalization of
something called the Quinta protesters
this is what we would call a free market
and this meant that for the first time
in Cubans could start small businesses
now there would still be a lot of
restriction for example they still
couldn't hire anybody and they could
only start a business that was one of
the types allowed by the government
however in the three years since these
became legal these freelancers are going
to represent 10% of the Cuban workforce
see see situation basically four people
were afraid of doing anything private
because government would take it away
from that but now the government trusts
the cuentapropistas because they are the
future but still hold on a minute
because there is more in fact Raul
Castro seems to be following the Chinese
Communist Party's playbook which by the
way is going to be the topic of another
video which we're going to be launching
very soon actually in a very dung
shopping style
Ralph Castro has created his very own
special economic zone this is the so
called marielle development zone so well
what does this mean well inside this
zone foreign companies are allowed to
start businesses they're allowed to hire
local people and they're able to trade
with less restrictions that exist in the
rest of Cuba
right foreign companies to Cuban and a
mixed one are the first eight companies
in the Meriel development zone which is
to return the main economical center of
Cuba
now imagine wondering how is it possible
some international companies such as the
Spanish hotel chain barceló are able to
operate in Cuba it's apparently the ban
on foreign companies there well if
you're watching this video from
somewhere outside of the United States
then you might well have traveled to
have varner at some point if that's the
case while you were there you were
probably staying in a bar cellar or
Amelia hotel both foreign companies so
these Spanish companies have been
operating in the country since the year
2000 but the truth is in order to
establish themselves on the island both
of these companies have to partner with
the Cuban government this means that the
hotels are owned by the local government
but the hotel chains have a license to
operate them and they get a share of the
profit so until now it was impossible to
start a company in Cuba unless you were
in partnership with the government so
the creation of this special economic
zone does show a clear trend a trend
that China saw in the 1990s further to
this there is a freeing up going on in
the housing market in just two years
over 40,000 new homes have been sold in
Cuba now this doesn't exactly mean the
Cubans have private property and the
transactions do come with a bowels and
restriction but it does highlight that
there is a trend going on in the country
that is another most important change in
recent times with Obama's announcement
that the trade embargo between the
United States and Cuba was coming to an
end the problem is is that still needs
to be passed by the American Congress
and with Donald Trump being the next
president it's very difficult to predict
exactly what's going to happen with that
deal when he controlled by Donald Trump
the Republican nominee for president
secretly conducted business in communist
Cuba during Fidel Castro's presidency
despite strict American trade bans that
made such undertakings illegal it's
according to interviews with former
Trump executives internal company
records and court filings
[Music]
it's from worse keep the embargo with
Cuba that's going to be bad news for
investors who live in the United States
they would lose out to investors who
come from other countries which don't
have such restrictions Britain Australia
Canada for example let a hold on a
second because there's still no
guarantee that Cuba's going to become
some sort of free-market paradise
especially not overnight it's not really
clear that even if you were legally
allowed to invest in Cuba whether that's
a good idea or not
in fact there are two potential
scenarios that could play out here one
option is that they follow the model of
Czechoslovakia which is now two
countries the Czech Republic and
Slovakia or it's possible they follow
the example of the Ukraine now let's
have a look at these two very different
examples
[Music]
Czechoslovakia versus Ukraine in 1990
both Czechoslovakia and the Ukraine
abandoned the communist based system but
there is a really big difference here
the Czechs had a revolution called The
Velvet Revolution to overthrow their
dictator and the new government led by
this guy on the screen now called fat
slob Havel he sent home the old guard
who had been ruling the country
meanwhile over in the Ukraine despite
the fact that they've got their
political independence they kept the
same old political elite their new
president Leonid croucher came from the
old Communist Party but this is not the
end of our story just like Cuba Ukraine
and Czechoslovakia have plans economies
where all of the companies belongs to
the government the first step in opening
up these economies to the wider world
was privatization but and this is really
important
not all privatizations are created
equally the Czechs to call it their
biggest companies and made a calculation
of the economic value then they divided
the economic value of these countries
into pouches if you were a Czech citizen
you could buy one of these vouchers for
a reasonable price something equal to
about a week's average salary this is
why 80% of the eligible population sport
in culture with this paper in your hand
view has the rights to buy some shares
in the company in order to help those
who didn't know how to bid for the
shares the Czech government encouraged
the creation of hedge funds these hedge
funds advise common citizens on how to
invest intelligently a Czech citizen was
able to go to one of these hedge funds
and say I want to get some shares of
this company and that one exception
now as you can probably imagine there
was a lot of corruption here but it also
had a really positive outcome it helps
the majority of Czechs to benefit from
the privatization of these national
company and the proof really is in the
pudding here it's 25 years later and the
Czech Republic is as egalitarian as
Germany and has a quality of life as
high as anywhere else in Europe
[Music]
but the story in Ukraine that's the
different matter
now the Ukraine did also tell these
vouchers to their citizens if you were a
Ukrainian citizen you could bid for a
voucher and eventually you were able to
use this voucher to buy some shares but
the reality of the matter is that the
government never got around to arranging
those auction it only really happened
with the smallest and worst of Ukraine's
companies and the Ukrainians were left
waiting for years they have their
vouchers in hand that they weren't able
to do anything useful with them and
unfortunately during this same time
Ukraine was also suffering from record
inflation when purchased these vouchers
would cost 1,500 American dollars but
some years later they were being
exchanged on the black market for as
little as ten US dollars so the average
Ukrainian would be sitting at home and
then oligarch would come knocking and
he'd say something like whoa what are
you going to do with that voucher it's
never going to be worth anything to you
tell you what you give it to me and I'll
give you some money that you can
actually use and surprise surprise soon
enough all of the vouchers were in the
hands of the oligarch and there's no
prizes for guessing here that yes the
oligarchs did have some pretty close
connections to the government who then
decided to auction off all of those
companies
[Music]
the outcome only those companies there
were interesting to the oligarchs were
sold and that is why Ukraine still has
to go through some privatization but the
most important thing to bear in mind
here is that in present-day Ukraine 85%
of the country's wealth is in the hands
of the 50 wealthiest oligarchs the
result is no political stability and a
horrific environment for investing oh
and that's not to mention the whole war
with Russia thing so if an investor is
bought a property in Kiev ten years ago
they might just be banging their head
against the wall right about now
all right so let's go back to Cuba here
we have some things that resemble
Czechoslovakia and we have some things
that resemble Ukraine for example in the
US you have two million Cubans living
this represents 20% of the entire Cuban
population these Cuban Americans have
been educated in a democratic system and
this could help build good democratic
institutions in Cuba if this does show
itself to be the case saying Kubik has
become a placed with rule of law civil
rights and many opportunities for Cubans
to lift themselves out of poverty so now
that we've given you the rundown on Cuba
and shared our opinion we would love to
know yours what do you think is going to
happen in Cuba do you think they'll
follow the path of the Czech Republic or
the path of Ukraine please let us know
in the comments below and also don't
forget that we put our brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday so don't
forget to subscribe to make sure that
you get all of those videos also if you
enjoyed this video please give it a
thumbs up below and I'll see you next
time
what they don't like